if i were to tell you that doctor who
had an episode
that crammed 2 billion years into 50
minutes
you might say that's a hell of a long
time personally
i think it's a hell of an episode
[Music]
heaven sent
it's funny i actually get nervous going
back
and watching episodes that i really love
because i'm afraid
that i'm going to see things wrong that
i missed before
you know things that were nitpicky that
i'd forgotten
about over time or aspects that i hadn't
absorbed the first time that on a
re-watch make me go oh
that's kind of a shame so with one that
i love as much
as heaven sent i was
nervous to come back and look at it with
a critical eye
because that's the point of this thing
this is still really really good
i love the ambition of it just on
premise
the fact that it is the doctor by
himself
nobody else not just no companion
no other characters for all intents and
purposes
like there's a child he talks to at the
very end there's the
monster there's his vision of clara but
she's not really there
and that does not count this is the
doctor
completely and utterly
alone and not knowing why
not knowing what's going on not knowing
how to get out of it
having to figure out and failing
again and again and again
except not actually failing
we'll get to the end in a little bit
but the whole thing this is one of those
episodes that that
is rewarding on a repeat viewing because
you can
knowing where it's going there's so much
more that you catch
the first time that you didn't catch
before in terms of
not necessarily foreshadowing but
elements that are
meant to feed into what is going on
there's a lot of them they are all over
the place and some of them you know get
flashback to again at the end but it's
fun to see them show up for the first
time in the episode
as you come to them everything from
finding the shovel
to him you know realizing
that he's being watched and that the
camera showed the vision of this thing
that is stalking him
all of it you know dropping the pedal
diving out the window oh god that was
that was the first moment that i was
like
because first of all the lead up to it
was fantastic and then he dives out the
window
and he basically jumps into his tardis
mind
palace to figure out what he's going to
do and this has actually been a thing
that the doctor has been doing across
this episode sort of
saying usually to other people in this
case
to effectively himself the things that
he does that keep him alive that keep
him
winning and you know he came up in
episodes like
the girl who died where he said you know
always act like you know what they're
playing because if you're very lucky
maybe they'll tell it to you
and here he said always assume that
you're going to survive
and then figure out how you did it slow
it down
and everything that goes through his
head
in that period of time while he's trying
to figure out
and so that's amazing i love that
clara's facing away from him
up until the very end i'm slightly torn
on whether
i think she should have turned around
and actually
faced him no i take that back
i used to be torn on that this time i'm
like no
it's important for the theming in terms
of
what the episode overall is doing so
right at the start
the doctor is stating his intent to hunt
down whoever is responsible
for this and stating openly that you
know clara told me not to seek revenge
you should know i don't always listen
i was i had to think about that like am
i annoyed by that line given what i said
before about
the idea of what's going to happen later
he kind of disregards clara's
um wishes and he's acknowledging that
here
i'm prepared to let it pass in this
instance though because that's him
coming out of the teleporter as far as
he's concerned
instantly after she died this is super
fresh for him
at the start of the episode so yeah oh i
get it that makes sense
what he's doing especially if he thinks
that
you know threatening might get him
somewhere i
really do enjoy that the doctor is
legitimately scared
of the situation he's in and of this
creature specifically this thing from
his nightmares his childhood nightmares
and i also think it's really well
integrated that
him admitting to that stops it that is a
great
planting of the idea of confession
across this question though
in case i forget to ask it later with
the confession dial
do the confession dials ever kill people
because the thing when it caught him if
he didn't confess
it did kill him now yes he looked back
around but that
didn't appear to be the design of the
thing that was
what he managed to do because it took
him a while to die and he dragged
himself back and reset
and basically started fresh again with
no memory of what was going on
but that didn't seem like how the thing
was designed to work
that was his work around so
do they just kill people through this
interrogation method
i i would assume so like especially
given that it doesn't tell you upfront
what's going on so the
unless you happen to stumble across
giving a true confession and stopping
the thing temporarily and realizing
that's what's going on
you probably are just going to get
killed actually strikes me as a super
inefficient
interrogation method if the person
doesn't know what's going on
but um that's that's kind of a meta
nitpick
it doesn't impact anything going on in
the moment
during the episode um for something that
is a little bit more of a
genuine nitpick the
the dropping of this idea of the hybrid
being a prophecy and being something
that the doctor knows but won't tell
there were many prophecies and stories
legends before the fact
one of them was about a creature
called the hybrid is not integrated very
smoothly into this
it's not completely crowbarred in but
it's not brought up organically it's
just kind of dropped in there
it's not the worst dropping of the term
hybrid that
this series has given us but it ain't
great and also related to that i i'm
gonna have to really pay attention
and hell bent for a number of reasons
but like
it doesn't establish why the doctor
knows what the hybrid is
and how the time lords know that he
knows
so like there's two layers of people
acting on information that i don't know
how the heck they have retained it that
doesn't help
again that's gonna more be an issue for
next time though
so i i wanna bring up the the thematics
of this and the creature
because i found myself wondering you
know what does this creature
represent and i because i've had a thing
lately of
you know recognizing some very specific
allegorical theming that
doctor has done and usually liking it
pretty well not always but usually
so i was trying to figure out is does
this thing represent
grief does it represent depression
you know what what exactly is this thing
and honestly it's interpretable as
a fair number of things i'll tell you
what it's
not though and like this is the one
thing i'll put a line under because
ultimately i don't think it has to be
any one thing but there's one thing that
it cannot be
it's not death
because i it kills him but it does not
represent death
thematically within the story because
you can't beat
death not even the doctor can beat death
and he does beat this thing at the end
through
persistence and stubbornness and so i
think something like depression or grief
i'm leaning towards grief is a much
better fit because
of the way the episode is structured
it is always following him
it is always at the back of his mind
and all he can do
is try and keep out of its reach
and when it grasps him he
he still has to get up and try again
and it's gonna take so many days
where that happens where the grief and
the pain
and the depression gets its claws into
him
and the next day he's still got to get
up and try again
over and over and over again because
getting over something this traumatic
takes time and takes work
and that's what the doctor is doing in
this episode
metaphorically putting in the work
and part of the reason why i feel it's
grief is what happens
towards the end when cara does actually
turn and face him and i said this this
factors into the theming because
there's a couple of things that he says
about mid-episode he said
the worst day isn't the day when you
lose someone
it's all the days after when they're
still gone
and that's what he's living through with
this
every day he's he resets has to
do it again and she's still not
there and then
at the end you know he's he's bemoaning
that fact
he says whatever i do you still won't be
here
and clara has three very simple words
for him
get over it because
you have to because grief
and depression will drag you down every
day
until you get over it and that can take
a lot of time that can feel like it
takes
2 billion years worth of time
before you break out of it
and feel the light again and don't feel
the breath of despair
on the back of your neck
but you can do it it's work it is
hard work it is pounding your fist
against a wall of
solid diamond kind of work but it's
work that you can do and you can get on
the other side of this
this episode is beautiful
and really does a great job
of dealing with the doctor's grief and
forcing him through the process of
coping with it
again and again and again and again and
again and again and again until he
actually conquers it
and is able to move forward in theory
here's the thing i tried to think if i
could come up with another
interpretation of this episode
because if i'm right
with how i read this episode
it makes hell bent all the worse because
of this episode is about
overcoming grief and how hard that is to
do
and how much work is involved in that
and the doctor puts that work
in then his actions in the next episode
almost completely undo that
at the very least severely undermine it
so i'll leave this as an option in the
comments
do people have other interpretations of
this
now even if there is one i'm still going
to be just inclined to take it just
because it makes hellbent work
better because this feeling this vibe
that i get from it that i've just shared
with you
is a huge part of why i love
this episode i mean the one other thing
that i love about it something that i
honestly can't ever recapture again
and that is the very first time that i
watched it it was
truly an emotional rollercoaster
so often when people say things are an
emotional rollercoasters and i watch
them
they feel more like just yo-yoing
tone here it was truly an emotional
rollercoaster at the end when i realized
that he kept dying and doing it over and
over and over again and then the number
of
times that he did it and was still doing
it
sunk in and i remember watching it for
the first time and i
felt this brick in my
gut weighing down just sink
and then i noticed he was getting
farther into the story of the shepherd's
boy
a little bit every time
it was the time when he gets as far as
and the shepherd's boy says
because initially he doesn't get very
he doesn't get that far and then after
that he says and the shepherds boy and i
didn't
it did i didn't notice that addition to
the story
but we said and the shepherd's boy says
that's when
it sunk in and i went from this
low emotional place feeling like i was
right there with him just being dragged
down to
hopeless despair and i shot to the moon
the joy and the thrill of realizing what
he was doing
and getting to see him do it was amazing
but like i said interpretation wise
i'm open to the possibility that maybe
i'm wrong but at the end of the day
truth be told i don't care
because my view of this episode is a
huge part of why i like it
and i'm not going to take on an
interpretation that i don't like as much
or that doesn't make as much sense to me
to try and salvage
what i'm about to watch
that's for next time for right now
heaven sent
is as good as i remember it
it is beautiful it is meticulous
it is expertly crafted
this is a phenomenal episode
heaven sent have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something out
down in the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon it
helps pay the bills around here and
keeps this entire operation afloat if
you're able to help me out there in any
amount there are perks for all tiers
i would greatly appreciate it even if
you can't though
liking sharing subscribing hitting the
bell those things help me out as
well so i would appreciate it certainly
but
you also don't have to because at the
end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]